ce qui ouvre cette troisième battle de
blackrock imac les talons alors donc
c'est un ado qui a l'habitude d'aller
voir sa grand mère quotidiennement puis
là il n'a pas vu depuis quelques jours
et il fera pas répond pas il ouvrait
puis 10 pts hammami ça pue la mort chez
toi mamie est ce qu'on pourrait s'il
vous plaît ouais donner une deuxième
chance à franck d'avancé à froid c'est à
toi ma vie donc ces trois corps s'y sont
ils sont sur la place du village et là
il ya la place avec la fontaine et puis
et puis il ya un bien petit gosse qui
courent kibua la fontaine et il ya un
des trois qui dit on va lui dire que
l'eau n'est pas potable
il va sans croiser on est le petit
moineau tu dis non je suis fatigué va
lui dire toi et ils continuent à boire
le petit continue à boire et l'autre
chez lui dit je vais lui dire [ __ ] bon
il s'approche il va voir le petit idiot
petit héros comme tu t'appelles je peux
t'y fais moi-même bois doucement va
[Applaudissements]
pas de la blague étalons c'est parti
alors c'est à l affiche un mec qui
drague des dragues
et puis il n'a jamais essayé une cougar
de salies en voix qui a pu et plus rien
il reste aux femmes de 22.3 pas
d'attention sakharov
non le tipi là il avait emballé toutes
les femmes sont belles comme chantait
frédéric françois quel que soit l'âge
s'il ya une très belle femme de 65 ans
mais elle a 45 ans puisque lui et c'est
d'y aller pourquoi pas il voit qu'elle
est réceptive
elle lui dit tu veux boire un verre chez
moi à l'ifa ok allons-y
et c'est quand même une belle femme
malgré la différence d'âge et il se
demande s'il va pouvoir assurer et oh et
puis commence à porter un peu et lui dit
ça te fait des raids de faire un plan
mère-fille suis très agréablement
surpris
enfin toujours fait partie de mes
fantasmes là franchement ça n'irait
ouais c'est un grand oui effet bouge pas
maman des sorts
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
thomas jane ça devient bon alors c'est
un couple très agile très agile de bias
en cinq ans et la ramasse en trois ans
jacques aux affaires là où commence à
voir le bout là encore mais subit donc
ils viennent chez un avocat ai dit voilà
on voudrait y vivre c'est l'avocat il
comprend pas et il met commence à vous
c'est un conte magnifique vous avez quel
âge
cent cinq ans on va appeler moi ça mais
en voudrez divorcé quand même c'est
quand même étrange ces boules ou
pourquoi pourquoi ces villas il dit non
moi je conseille jamais raison bien
entendu avait mais alors comment ça se
fait vous avez attendu quand même ou si
longtemps bas les filets il est resté
municipal plat du jour
c'est une langue de boeuf dit ça à pas
je vais pas sortir un truc qui sort de
la bouche d'un animal de new age of
carols toujours tourner encore une
élégante mois vas-y quelle femme n
cacahuètes dans le cul ah bon je sais
qui c'est c'est guy c'est la femme
arachides
alors là tu as confiance qu'est-ce-qui
qu'est-ce qui est jaune
ouais et qui traverse les murs c'est
quoi un super plus à une base and magic
huleux je suis passé par la suite
alors c'est une blonde qui décide
d'aller voir un spectacle de
ventriloquie donc avoir un ventre et
l'a40 dans la dans la salle le spectacle
commandes donc le le ventriloque dia il
a avec son appareil sur la fin du roman
on va commencer par faire des blagues
sur les blondes est allé se lève et pète
un câble et diallo ont pas faire de
blagues sur les blondes
on en a marre des blagues sur les
blondes et tout est le ventriloque
l'arrière du team dams est un spectacle
c'est des blagues hadji toi ta gueule
sur la pointe je parle
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
c'est un type de rendre dans un magasin
du sentier et il voit le tipi c'est
bonjour monsieur le tiff et bonjour
comment ça va ça va et son enfance dites
moi je voudrais savoir si vous avez du
tissu rouge
il fait rouge il va dans l'arrière
boutique vient avec un tissu vert il
fait j'ai vu j'ai ouvert aux chevaux une
merveille ce ver tiens et si le gazon la
campagne tic tout manque les arbres et
en fait c'est nous pas radine cercil
merveille de verre fait excuser moi je
veux pas vous contredire mais moi ce que
je dresse du rouge a du rouge bien sûr
alors pourquoi pas il va y revient que
du bleu faisaient que si vous vous
concentrez bien sûr ce bleu voyez des
dauphins qui sort qui vante les baleines
des teams qui pêchent le sable ça me
tromper les filles dansent les batteries
ai fait écouter c'est pas du bleu et du
vert que je veux c'est dur ou s'éclaire
du rouge à vous énervez pas du rouge
s'est réjouie
attendez je reviens mais trop bien
éclater issue prince de galles saucisses
u10 u11 2 il veut m'acheter moi je veux
pas le vendre je me bats lui ment parce
que j'attendais le qui allait avec ce
tissu tellement ces merveilles se situer
et vous avez la tête la tête d'ubs reims
pour acheter ce tissu prince de galles
aussi nous prend la tête il le fera
quatre étoiles a fait espèce de cola
c'est du rouge que je veux tu rouge sang
tentures rouges tu fais du rouge
on n'a pas
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
petite blague familiale d'accord nous
sommes dans un hôtel il ya un mari qui
appelle la réception qui dit écoutez je
vais avoir une discussion avec ma femme
c'est très très grave elle veut se jeter
par la fenêtre vous venir rapidement le
maire luigi nono désolé mais ça c'est un
problème personnel
diarra n'ont pas du tout les fenêtres ne
s'ouvrent pas c'est un problème de
maintenance muscles
[Applaudissements]